nicolaïf comme de nombreuses villes en
Ukraine depuis plusieurs mois et mes
connaissables à moins de 100 km de
Kerson territoire
occupé par la Russie nicolaïf est une
cible de choix pour l'armée russe qui
bombarde régulièrement la ville les
longues files d'attentes pour aller
chercher de l'eau sont devenus
récurrentes la zone n'est plus
approvisionnée en eau depuis avril les
forces russes sont coupées les conduites
qui alimentaient la ville
le temps d'attente le plus long c'était
3h30 c'était au début de la guerre
personne n'avait de brouette j'avais
récupéré 30 litres d'eau
côté nourriture la situation est
similaire dans cette école transformée
en point de distribution les citoyens
reçoivent le minimum de rations
alimentaires
en ce moment je ne mange que du pain et
des conserves c'est déjà presque l'hiver
et c'est terrifiant
à l'approche de l'hiver une grande
partie de la région et s'engage et sans
électricité
une solution pour pallier le froid ses
poils spécialement construits et livrés
aux habitants qui constitueront pour
beaucoup le seul élément qui les
garderont au chaud tout l'hiver
pour être à l'abri des bombardements les
gens dorment dans les sous-sols ses
poils seront installés là pour que les
gens dorment au chaud
les récentes frappentus sont ciblées
spécifiquement les infrastructures
ukrainiennes et anéanti environ 40% des
structures énergétiques du pays